this video is brought to you by full
sail university
what's up everybody michael here now
today we're talking about the show
that's convinced me to never attend a
superhero orgy ever no matter what this
most recent season of the boys has been
both chaotic and wildly compelling and
if homelanders recent antics have shown
us anything it's that kanye was right no
one manned should have all that power
but it's not just homelander and his new
radioactive daddy whose lives are
defined by power it's all of them
whether they're as helpless as huey or
as formidable as starlight every single
player is being forced to play the same
power game so why are all of these
characters so obsessed with power and
can the power struggles and the boys
teach us something about how power
functions in our own societies let's
find out with a little help from some
french philosophers frenchie would be so
proud of us
welcome to this wisecrack edition on the
boys is power going to kill us all and
of course major spoilers ahead for the
latest season of the boys
but before we get into it i want to
shout out this video sponsor full sail
university full sail offers associates
bachelors and master's degrees in the
fields of technology arts media and
entertainment and they just launched a
new bachelor's degree in game business
and esports which can help students
enter the industry from different
perspectives from game development to
communications and marketing to
competitive gaming itself and this new
major joins a roster of other cool
fields of study like film production
computer animation sports casting and
web development with full sail
university's accelerated coursework you
can finish your degree in about half the
time required at other colleges and
universities plus you can complete your
classes and coursework online or in
person at full sales campus in orlando
depending on what's right for you
whatever model you choose you'll get
hands-on real-world experience in the
career path of your choice plus full
sail accepts new enrollments monthly so
you don't have to build your schedule
around traditional semesters to learn
more about full sail university's new
game business and esports majors or any
of their other degree programs visit
fullsail.edu
wisecrack that's fullsale.edu wisecrack
and now back to the show the boys puts
power front and center since we're
dealing with a world where some people
can leap buildings or obliterate an
innocent woman in a single bound but
just as importantly a whole lot of
people can't and all of this sounds in
line with michelle foucault's analysis
of how power functions in society one
form of power he identifies sovereign
power describes the right of those at
the top to give and take life or to put
it more simply the right to kill we see
a lot of this in modern political
philosophy in this view of power there's
a small contingent at the top who can
take all of us out at will and then
we're just down at the bottom hoping
that they don't and ever since a train
plowed through huey's girlfriend and
homelander took out an entire plane to
protect the company the boyz has been
exploring how dangerous this type of
sovereign power really is and how those
who wield it rarely face consequences
this is why at least initially it seems
like we're watching a valiant quest by
butcher and the boys to level the
playing field by overthrowing the soups
and the force of their sovereign power
but as we go further down the vaught
rabbit hole it becomes clear that the
power problem isn't limited to the
wielding of power by a powerful
sovereign a la what hobbs and the modern
political philosophers talked about
rather power is more defined by what
foucault describes as rules according to
which the true and false are separate
and specific effects of power which are
attached to the true a battle about the
status of truth and the economic and
political role it plays in this way
power is something that's sort of
everywhere and enacted more than it's
possessed the boys are on a mission to
prevent anyone from wielding that type
of power ever again but as we go further
down the vaught rabbit hole it becomes
clear that the power problem isn't
limited to a train in co it's everywhere
along with starlight huey has been the
closest thing the show has to a moral
compass we sympathize with him because
he's been victimized by multiple members
of the seven and he's way more
compassionate than most of the show's
alpha males plus he's just sort of
adorable and wears really great t-shirts
but he still lives in a world where
value is measured in power and the a
train action figures in his bedroom show
us that he grew up admiring soups he
desires power but has spent most of his
life without it and the tension this
creates soon starts bubbling up in
unpleasant ways some of which involve
intravenous drug use and green puke
now huey's frustration seems to come
from a good place he's watched his loved
ones being harmed without being able to
help so he wishes he was stronger but
there's something else going on and it
manifests in his insecurity about dating
a soup the struggle to open a jar
threatens his sense of manhood even when
they're safe at home on some level huey
feels entitled to be more powerful than
starlight is simply because he's a man
his sense of worth is derived from how
powerful he feels specifically relative
to his incredibly powerful girlfriend i
thought that you didn't care about that
i mean on our first
date
you said that it didn't bother you i
know
but it does
sometimes but this isn't just a huey
problem society prioritizes power which
we see in the throngs of sad sacks
obsessed with homelander all getting off
on his all-encompassing power this
seemingly harmless but toxic dudeness is
exemplified by todd a classic nice guy
type he's a glasses-wearing flannel
shirt-clad teacher and caring stepfather
and husband but we learned that
underneath the nice guy exterior is a
dark obsession with homelander and his
most toxic and violent beliefs because
he's america's greatest hero who saves
thousands of people he's standing up to
the crooks the corporations and the
legacy media hey you friend me on
facebook i'll send you some stuff i mean
okay let's just say right now um in
particular in season three they're doing
a trump thing i mean you saw the taco
bowl scene right seriously we have the
best taco bowls right here in the
building should make you feel right at
home pal
bienvenidos
trump literally did that and the whole i
could shoot someone on fifth avenue and
nothing would happen thing where i could
stand in the middle of fifth avenue and
shoot somebody and i wouldn't lose any
voters okay well that happens too and it
goes just about as well as old don
senior predicted yeah
[Applause]
and while hughie doesn't have todd's
dark obsession with homelanders fascist
world view he does fall into the same
trap of being the nice guy who
fetishizes the power of others the
introduction of temp v allows huey to
experience the physical power that a
train and homelander have used to ruin
his life and the transformation is
stunning formerly peaceful huey starts
killing people with his bare hands
well naked
i'm sorry if i was murdered by a fully
clothed man i would feel a sense of
honor i was murdered by a naked person i
would feel shame i'd feel nothing
because i'd be dead but assuming that
the afterlife exists and consciousness
transcends into the afterlife i would
feel shame we can better understand
what's going on here with another type
of power that foucault talks about
biopower voco describes it as an
explosion of numerous and diverse
techniques for achieving the subjugation
of bodies and the control of populations
biopower is another mechanism by which
societies can control who lives or dies
while ensuring the health of a stable
workforce this can look like i don't
know like government's deciding when
life begins and what bodies containing
life are allowed to do with them sorry i
know that was a super hypothetical
example i'll do a better one next time
and in the world of the boys both
compound v and temp v represent advances
in a type of biopower by which certain
humans literally have more biological
power which they can decide to use to
hurt or to help people so huey's
pacifism empathy and loyalty to
starlight all dwindle as soon as he's
jacked up on that v it's almost as if he
was just using these virtues as crutches
that once empowered he no longer found
useful i thought the drugs had [__]
you up huey but
this is you
this is all you luckily by the end of
the season we learned that huey isn't in
fact a total power-hungry piece of [__]
literally every neuron in your brain is
screaming i told you so so why don't you
just say it before your head explodes oh
my god i [__] told you so but not
everyone comes back to the light after
tasting some power and power dynamics
aren't exclusive to the men the show's
female characters also find themselves
forced to compromise their values if
they want to enjoy agency or authority
take the shameless corporate climber
ashley i accept your nomination as ceo
of vaught international
you know my mother used to say before
she
died of cancer when i was 17. okay
ashley that's enough let's not bring the
room down apology sir having worked her
way to the top and vaught she gets a
front row seat to homelanders brutal
corporate culture but being humiliated
every day by those above her doesn't
inspire ashley to change the system or
challenge its legitimacy though it does
lead to her ripping out her own hair
instead she just soaks up all their
abuse and unleashes it on those not as
strong as her the next report you're
gonna be doing is inside my [__]
[__] putting women like ashley in
positions of power seems like it should
challenge the patriarchal culture at
vaught that at least is the theory of
the lean in brand of feminism sometimes
called corporate feminism which has been
championed by the likes of former
facebook ceo sheryl sandberg the
thinking goes that women climbing their
ranks can change things from the inside
tipping the balance and fundamentally
altering sexist power structures unlike
most third wave feminists corporate
feminism doesn't view capitalism as part
and parcel with gender inequality rather
it argues that equality comes when
capitalism diversifies it's sort of like
saying that you know the planet of
alderaan would still exist if the death
star were pink in reality and much like
ashley sandberg's been accused of
wielding her power in less than savory
ways she reportedly yelled at and
intimidated employees when they tried to
speak up about facebook's role in
russia's campaign to influence the 2016
election and she reportedly failed to
act decisively to stop the prolific
dissemination of right-wing extremism
racism and misogyny on the platform but
to be clear to the best of our knowledge
sandberg has never been complicit in any
murders or kidnapping that we're aware
of
on the show ashley embraces a type of
lean in feminism even as she's actively
harming the women around her she ends up
mimicking homelanders example is your
idiot brain getting by stupid is your
idiot brain getting by stupid several
other female characters do the same
before homelander went all raiders of
the lost ark on her madeleine stillwell
was able to hold some sway over the
super powered man baby but only by
indulging his edible fantasies our boy
likes to drink that milk
also in this season he milks a cow to
suck its teeth because his edible
fantasies transition to farm animals but
you know we don't we don't kink shame at
wisecrack nope and madeline had no
qualms with all types of murder and
intimidation and bribery as long as it
helped her climb the corporate ranks
even super-powered women are forced to
occupy a specific version of the strong
woman archetype when she joins the seven
starlight's costume is immediately
reinvented to make it more revealing you
know for the fellas she can be strong
just as long as she's also sexy and
while vodka is out of its way to
highlight how empowered its female
heroes are with their girls get it done
slogan girls get it done
they always ensure that their vision of
a powerful woman does nothing to
challenge the authority of the
patriarchy wow i'm so honored to be with
you guys tonight to celebrate my dear
friend
and mentor
homelander even when they seem to be
acting outside the bounds of
conventional gender roles they're still
just playing with power
stormfront's whole identity was based
around rejecting the traditional
feminine qualities of someone like
starlight this world for confusing nice
with good be a [__] if you want be
whatever just drop the mask once in a
while but this not like other girls
branding was only skin deep because her
casual nazism still comes in a
conventionally feminine package yay it's
a lot like the cool girl archetype from
gone girl where her subversions are
acceptable in so much as they don't
challenge gender roles themselves also
at the end of the day she still ends up
being homelanders half dead hj machine
when you lead an army of aryan
ubermensch to their victory
what the key thing here is that no
matter how high any of them climb the
moment they stop playing along with the
powers that be the moment they
improperly express empathy
they can be easily thrown under the bus
or tossed into a secret prison or just
taken out altogether
this makes any kind of solidarity almost
impossible vaught takes full advantage
of the women's disunity when it wants to
get rid of queen maeve while positioning
her as a symbol of empowered queer
womanhood was great for marketing the
moment she starts to speak out she
vanishes and when starlight appeals to
ashley's humanity to try and find her we
see a split second of empathy and then i
am ceo
next time appointment from soft boys
like huey to super women like starlight
what the third season of the show really
underlines is how difficult it is to
actually take a stand
against the types of power that
philosophers like foucault talk about
when describing his theory of biopower
he says that if genocide is indeed the
dream of modern power this is not
because of the recent return for the
ancient right to kill it is because
power is situated and exercised at the
level of life the species of the race
and the large-scale phenomena of the
population which means that modern power
uses as much force as necessary to
maintain the structure of a governable
society nobody wants innocent people to
get hurt of course not
but sadly
well the bad guys
they don't think like us
and so
sometimes
well these things just happen
now we can better understand what's
going on here by visiting another pair
of french thinkers jill gilda luz and
felix guaterrie who we would assume
frenchie has definitely read while in a
philosophical k-hole you know jean-paul
sartre said
marriage staffers are essential male
urges their work understands modern
power via the lens of capitalism and how
human desire is structured and then used
by capitalism this allows them to
analyze how capitalism seems to be able
to suck everything up into its own orbit
infinitely increasing its own power and
control according to de las everything
is rational in capitalism except capital
or capitalism itself the stock market is
certainly rational one can understand it
study it the capitalists know how to use
it and yet it is completely delirious
it's mad it is in the sense that we say
the rational is always the rationality
of an irrational this is a key tension
of how power operates under capitalism
it makes logical sense i.e we can
understand how markets and profits work
in mathematical terms but it's also
totally bad [__] when we realize how
these logical systems affect society and
human life it makes logical sense that
student loan debt comes with compounding
interest but it makes absolutely no
sense that a kindergarten teacher can
rack up six figures in growing debt and
we see this in vaught a publicly traded
corporation that makes logical decisions
based on how it affects the market and
their profitability even when the
reality of those decisions involves
murdering innocent humans or
experimenting on children and empowering
a super-powered psychopath it's what
makes homelanders such a perfect
metaphor for this kind of capitalist
fueled power he's literally bulletproof
able to shrug off any attack any
criticism any call for accountability
because at the end of the day he still
has all the power and as long as his
power doesn't contradict the logic of
capital everything is fine and that's
what people who really want to change
things are up against a powerful
structure that can logically justify
taking you out if you're with their
profits and that has the biopower to
kill you with ease
take the three characters who seemed
like they were leading the charge
against vaught and homelander starlight
billy butcher and victoria newman
they're each taking different approaches
to changing things with butcher aiming
for a violent insurrection newman hoping
to bring about political change via the
democratic process and starlight trying
to fix thought from the inside now
initially it seems like they're all
making a difference butcher is
effectively tracking down dangerous
superheroes while reining in his most
violent impulses newman is leading the
bureau of superhero affairs to try and
keep those with powers within the bounds
of the law and starlight has been made
co-captain of the seven seemingly
putting her on equal footing with
homelander it looks like real change is
coming but that idea is quickly set on
fire snapped in half and stomped into
the dirt and then it gets its head blown
up
newman is revealed to be in vaught's
pocket this makes sense as the
corporation is so powerful that it can
own everyone on both sides of the
political divide propping up progressive
politicians to maintain the impression
of a functioning democracy without
risking vaught's own authority oh and
newman is of course also a soup who can
blow people's heads up but hey um at
least this is just a tv show you know
it's not like corporate interests would
ever have a direct relationship with
seemingly progressive politicians
that um that allowed them to ensure that
they stayed in power while pacifying the
masses into thinking the politicians
were fighting for them because that'd be
crazy
right like if politicians took money
from the oil industry the weapons
industry the tech industry and then they
were like oh no but we could we care
about you you know that's that's tv
stuff okay grow up if you think that's
how the world works that's tv it's not
how the world works for de luz and
guitare none of this fundamentally
contradicts how capital works because
ideology doesn't really matter
only power does de luz says in an
interview that ideology has no
importance whatsoever what matters is
not ideology not even the economic
ideological distinction or opposition
but the organization of power because
organization of power that is the manner
in which desire is already in the
economic in which libido invests the
economic haunts the economic and
nourishes political forms of repression
okay this means that underneath a sort
of social performance of ideology and
politics like what we see from newman is
really just a raw desire for power you
have 193 million instagram followers let
me your influence and i'll lend you mine
i can protect you from homelander you'll
finally be team captain for real and in
return you help me goose my numbers this
isn't just about one politician secretly
being corrupt but a system where power
is so concentrated into the hands of
corporations like vaught that no one can
even enter the game without their say-so
huey might have thought that he and
newman were making all the right chess
moves to take vot down but it turns out
vaught owned the whole board from the
beginning and newman was playing along
because she gets that it's about power
and not ideology the same goes for
starlight going from a simple country
girl to the head of the executive table
she's exactly the sort of success story
that lean in feminism craves living
proof that talented and committed women
can smash through the glass ceiling and
rise to the top of course it's quickly
revealed that vaught is still
underpinned by the same values it always
was namely that they'll say and do
whatever makes their stock price go up
feminism is useful if it's profitable
and helps them sell merch and that's
about it we always seem primed to
celebrate individual advancements
individual advancements of black people
people of color women without taking
into consideration that diversity by
itself may simply mean that previously
marginalized individuals have been
recruited to guarantee a more
efficient
operation of oppressive systems on the
back of numerous scandals it is briefly
beneficial to vaught to put starlight
front and center to make them look
progressive again they are using the
power of the media to create a regime of
truth that helps maintain their position
but when homelander tears up the ratings
with a maniacal rant about his own
innate superiority fascism comes right
back into fashion i am done apologizing
i am done being persecuted for my
strength you people
should be thanking christ that i am who
and what i am because you need me
you need me to save you
you do
i am the only one who possibly can
and none of this would have shocked the
lutz who said that fascism too one must
say that it has assumed the social
desires including the desires of
repression and death people got hard-ons
for hitler for the beautiful fascist
machine though now it's not hard-ons for
hitler but hard-ons for homelander and
kids if you thought philosophy was
boring that's a famous french
philosopher who wrote the line people
got hard-ons for hitler so
major in philosophy the one major where
you can write a paper that says the
phrase hard-ons for hitler and not get
sent to the counseling center the
overarching message of the boy's third
season is that the capitalist power
structure can adapt
to just about anything in most cases it
can even absorb it outright and find a
way to make money off of it the sick
genius of capitalism according to de
luzari is that since it's fundamentally
about the logic of power and desire and
not ethics or ideologies it can suck up
anything into its orbit as long as it
can help increase profits whether it's a
train's cynical attempt to use the black
lives matter movement to propel himself
back into relevancy or the way vaught
turns on a dime from forcing maeve to
cover up her sexuality to using her to
rainbow wash the company's image even
the things which were specifically
created to curtail their power can be
sucked up into the big machine and spat
back out as consumer products starlight
realizes this when newman offers her the
latest in a long line of ends justify
the means type propositions she's sick
of being drawn into a rigged game and
vows to fight from the outside instead
like one of deluz's favorite literary
characters melville's bartleby the
scrivener rather than playing along
starlight simply says i would prefer not
to and rejects the system she also
rejects a more sovereign view of power
when she uses her instagram live to
wield power through knowledge and media
influence she realizes it's entirely
possible that our french friends were
right that there is no real outside and
no way to challenge the system as deeply
ingrained as the one vaught represents
but she sure as hell gonna try
done i'm not doing it anymore
you're not gonna be doing anything if
homelander kills you yeah maybe
but then all know i'm not working with a
nut job of course whether she'll be
successful is unclear we already know
that incremental solutions just won't
work that the whole system is broken and
needs to be completely rebuilt so long
as their lives are defined by a desire
for power they'll only be safe once they
have it and that's the lesson which
everyone from huey to starlight has been
beaten over the head with throughout the
third season and while our friends don't
magically dismantle the economic and
psychic hold of capitalism by season's
end we do see some rejections of the
illogical logic of this system huey
realizes how utterly effed up his search
for power in the temp v was and by
reflecting on his father's love for him
he realizes that actual strength comes
from taking care of those we love you
know what dad
was there
taking care of me during during the
worst days of his life just trying to
keep the lights on and
the roof above our heads this enables
him to throw away the temp v and use his
not decaying brain to very literally
empower starlight to fight fascism and
in doing so this shows that huey is
rejecting a sort of old-school sovereign
view of power and enacting a sort of
power that he has some control over and
we see maeve seemingly sacrifice her
life to protect others but none of these
virtuous or just x take place within the
system of vots superhero industrial
complex it's not enough to just get some
of the right people further up the
pyramid they won't have any more effect
on it than the people sitting next to
homelander it's about pulling the blocks
out from the very bottom and watching it
collapse so that we can build something
new but as we see in homelanders once
good natured son ryan some people can't
help but be attracted to the power
promised by the system in its
exploration of power both at the
biological level of soups who can
dominate the rest of humanity and at the
level of a larger system which runs on
the cold logic of capital the boys seems
to be pointing to the way in which our
own world isn't all that different sure
we don't have magical juice that we can
shoot up to help us teleport in the buff
or superhumans who can laser decapitate
a protester with impunity but we do have
corporations working alongside the
government to profit off weapons and
power social and political figures
tapping into populist anger folks from
across the identity spectrum climbing
the corporate ladder and crushing the
folks below them on the way up and
politicians or maybe more into good pr
that's why i proposed and
and the house nancy put it in the plan
to immediately provide
ten thousand dollars in debt relief as
stimulus right now than they are
actually doing the stuff they promised
to do when we elected them and much like
the show itself we're left wondering if
those of us without any type of
superpower whether that be strength
money or influence are left to get
symbolically at least run over by those
in power
but what do you guys think is this sort
of imbalance just a fact of life
or can we ever hope to change things let
us know what you think in the comments a
big thanks to all our patrons for your
support please don't forget to check out
our new patreon features if you haven't
already and check out our new stream
wisecrack live taking place right here
thursdays at 11am hit that like button
like you're slamming closed a copy of
lean in and don't forget to ring that
bell and subscribe as always thanks for
watching later
[Music]
[Applause]
but if you know someone or you or a
loved one have been kidnapped or
murdered by sheryl sandberg
shout it out in the comments